est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour
l'interview réaction en chaîne moi non
- non je ne fais pas interdit aux
réactions aux chaînes enfants dont
messieurs on se concentre mon petit
ramsey que je vous kiffe terrible savez
je sais on vous propose un plan à 3
qu'est ce que j'ai fait
on a bien si on prend la mienne oui on a
déjà joué là bas record à 3 les mairies
voilà j'avais minutes j'aurais pas dû
l'être a dit je suis fan
une femme une femme superbe coucher avec
vous car avec une femme malade si c'est
pas mal à briller
or disent tous que je prochaine sortie
bredouille
je resterai en baisse jusqu'à tr min ce
mois tu veux que je laisse la classe
naturelle grand addition qui défendent
leurs idées d'où il est humain comme les
jo la bidouille
mais ça c'est mignon mais moins que les
gens n'a plus gardé une femme super de
toucher avec vous car et vous prend pour
gad elmaleh qu'est ce que vous faites
gad et le mal est arrivé apparemment
même chaîne
c'est un cerisier ou non qu'un calme toi
voilà ça doit être difficile parce que
physiquement on a pas c'est pas super
proches n'ont qu'à d'el maleh et nous
mais disons moi j'y vais quand même moi
aussi j'aurais malentendu c'est bon
aussi et après je lui conseille un
opticien une femme superbe coucher avec
vous elle vous propose même un million
d'euros personne ne le saura jamais ce
que vous êtes d'accord moi je pense que
ma famille regarder non non je vais
coucher pour de l'argent alors bien sûr
que oui c'est vrai il n'ya même pas
besoin de dire une femme superbe
il
bazire avec l'homme
au planning du quart des postes à san
luis
je donne moi ton avis moi ça n'a pas
aidé mme agnetha bon c'est manito manu
tout ça c'est pas parce que le moigne et
aux idées très haut mais en plus il faut
quatre boutons 3 et 4 mai concernant ce
rachat de résoudre c'est toi je trouve
super dont ma mère je trouve incroyable
au carré carré blanc
ob craint et on savait les teasers
motivant [ __ ] on savait pas si on
allait réussir va vous envoyer en
vacances ensemble et je te doivent régir
1200 francs motion il peut plus trouver
les français voilà je te jure en te
rendrai jamais ton argent je sais je
sais de toute manière je suis certain
qu'il va me faire mais je rendrai jamais
ta et seraient donc peut être pas de
masters à la télé tu te rendrai jamais
été saoul au quotidien nikkei mais je te
rendrai teyssieu faire tu peux rien
faire c'est dommage basile peu moins un
truc
c'est pas chanter les mazures
un jeu
ça quel état ils m ont promis sur leurs
gardes
non non vous battez pas vous battez pas
là bah ouais mais là c'est là c'est la
guerre et la phase i dig digne il
regarde jamais le club apparemment vous
ayez perdu 4 à chaque personne qui me
jette de l'eau alors c'était un petit
job c'est de vivre oui
alors assez vote jamais le [ __ ] parce
que je m'excuse mais je m'excuse j'ai
été nul sur ce coup là si tu fais un
poutou s'est excusé fais gaffe va te
faire un coup de trash crasse jeunes on
n'en sait guère foot ou un vrai vrai nom
je veux vous regarde ce qu'ils font je
veux une remise une remise de chèques
c'est parce que je veux dire ça veut
dire poser mais pas de bruit pas de
bruit pas de bruit et un petit mot
gentil on dans les yeux un petit boulot
ou je fais ça s'arrête pas là ce film
est un frère yves l'arabie vas-y islam
modéré de la mode et non après le
message non le message non tu que tu
sois tu vas ça me fasse face à face
action action sur mon gentil accès aux
messages et maintes et maintes fois
mentionné jeudi - de tes trucs mieux
rebondir là j'suis super pas bien pour
la tête de ma mère je suis pas bien la
méridienne des trucs
le messager va dire le message pourquoi
les bennes
action réaction djamel message qu est-ce
qui a dit pas ça c'est trop c'est bien
ce mois là tu es bien rasé qui peut
pleurer à volonté amélie pleure oui pour
qu'il me dise maintenant la série law
c'est c'est le meilleur comique d'humour
c'est toi le meilleur comique du monde
du web
installez vous monsieur le ministre
l'islam l'islam modéré et clame
intempestifs progressiste c'est un peu
un beau message de l'islam sympa parce
qu'on a toujours les l'image de l'islam
who is love en fait un de l'islam
agressif de l'islam barbu et tout est là
il ya l'islam classe moi j'aime bien le
verbe moi qui suis catholique catholique
super je trouve ça génial
sérieux c'est c'est de loin avec eux que
j'ai pris le plus de plaisir à la
télévision posez moi c'était les
vacances en présence étaient des
vacances à la main berne mignon
catholique super islam vision de l'autre
bisous islam un bisou bisou
le cos
10h19 mais c'est le mais c'est le
principal c'est ça le pire c'est que moi
je connais que ça un rationnement qui
suis catholique super ouais je reconnais
que des islams d'où des islams
bisounours mais islam se claque quoi
booster avec 20 mètres l'islam à la mode
en nouvelle tutelle le concept que je
voudrais aussi en france toujours serrés
abdallah salah
le truc que j'aurai lancé c'est le
concept de gentle beurre non c est que
tous les beurs tous les robots de france
qui se reconnaîtront dans cette ère avec
de l'oussouet l'allemagne et bien
c'était qu'on se réunisse tous pour
montrer qu'elle dans des clubs en a la
classe mais on fait des gardes
non c'est moi et des loukoums et le jour
où ça ça sera bien fédérer on sera un
mouvement très très fort et ça changera
les moeurs à ce moment là rien au hasard
on bosse là dessus john turner mais pas
une veste à fond une veste qu'est ce
qu'on fait en continu
vous trouvez un moyen faillite de pas
payer vos impôts qu'est ce que vous
faites
moi ça me gêne mois de papier mais un
plan les impôts c'est tendu ça bah oui
parce que ça fait des écoles et des
routes et où annoncée rarement et des
routes qui traversent des écrans plus où
est ce assez secondaire à cette
précarité raposa par contre peut-être
pourquoi même par exemple on doit bosser
ça donc je mange quand même c'est vrai
vous voyez david douillet frapper un
enfant pour lui piquer des pièces jaunes
qu'est ce que pour eux
vous faites bon le tabac ça avec lui
mais en traite une fois que l'enfant
elle reste inanimée
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu